today on the matt walsh show pfizer is
seeking an emergency authorization to
start giving a vaccine to kids aged 5 to
11. but what's the emergency exactly and
what will we do when the government
starts mandating this stuff to young
children also gang members in chicago
get into a shootout in broad daylight
and the d.a has decided to charge none
of them with crimes at all plus a school
shooting in texas has the left screaming
about gun control again but as always
they're missing the point and in our
daily cancellation we'll discuss the
tick tocker who claims that almost all
men are rapists all of that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you may think that you can go online
maybe put your browser in incognito mode
and your online activity uh will be
private but it's not as simple as that
um there are many ways that that these
companies can still track your internet
activity and that means to really stop
people from seeing the sites you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop a
hotel or even your parent's house
without expressvpn every site you visit
could be logged by the admin of that
network and that's still true even when
you're in incognito mode i mean do you
really want your parents to see what
you've been looking at i mean personally
i wouldn't care if they did but i mean i
don't want to know about all these the
details of things you look at it on when
you're on your computer what's more your
home internet provider can also see and
record your browsing data and in the u.s
they're legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers expressvpn is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers so that your private
online activity stays just that private
so stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.comwalsh
use my link at expressvpn.com walsh to
get three extra months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.comwalsh to learn more
well you know the censorship has gotten
so extreme that i'm not even sure if
this episode will see the light of day
given what i'm going to say here at the
beginning there's no reason why it ought
to be taken down of course there's no
reason why any opinion ought to be
censored but there's just no telling how
our big tech overlords will react these
days the rules are arbitrary for a
reason and yet some important points i
think still need to be made about this
the former fda commissioner scott
gottlieb
um appeared
on cbs to express optimism
that the pfizer cova vaccine might be
available to children aged 5 to 11
by as early as this halloween let's
listen
lastly the ceo of pfizer the company you
started on the board of affirmed today
that that data on vaccinations for five
to 11 year olds will be going to the fda
within a matter of days um
is that confirming your schedule of
vaccines by halloween yeah i think
that's still possible um fda has said
that the review is going to be a matter
of weeks not months i i interpret that
to mean potentially a four week review
maybe a six week review so i think on
the on on the low end it could take four
weeks and that could give you a vaccine
by halloween if it slips a little could
be mid-november
now it should be noted that pfizer is
asking for an emergency authorization to
start injecting the stuff into kids but
what is the emergency exactly
kids are doing fine covet is no serious
threat to them why do we need to rush
this out like it's an emergency when it
isn't
an article on nbc.com has more it says
pfizer and bioentech announced thursday
that they had submitted an emergency
request to the u.s food and drug
administration for authorization of the
company's two-dose coven-19 vaccine in
children ages 5 to 11.
with new cases and children in the u.s
continuing to be at a high level this
submission is an important step in our
ongoing effort against kova 19.
this is from pfizer we're committing
committed to working with the fda with
the ultimate goal of helping protect
children against this serious public
health threat an fda advisory committee
plans to meet to discuss authorization
on october 26th the company said last
month that the vaccine was safe in
children 5 to 11 and showed a quote
robust antibody response based on data
collected in a trial that included more
than 2 000 children during the trial
children were given two smaller doses
than those given to people who are 12
and older pfizer said that the shots
produced antibody responses and side
effects that were comparable to those
seen in a similar study of people 16 to
25 who receive the full dose of the
vaccine
now okay well new coveted cases are at a
high level pfizer says
pretty broad just at a high level
what pfizer forgets to mention is that
those cases six million in total and
that includes kids of all ages not just
five to 11.
but those six million cases have
resulted in death for a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of a percent of
them
even hospitalization rates according to
the american academy of pediatrics could
be as low as 0.1
the vast majority of cases result in
mild symptoms or no symptoms
this is not a serious public health
threat for kids
not for kids anyway it is for their
great grandparents
who are almost all vaccinated by now
but it's not for them
kids already have through their natural
immune system greater protection from
covid than vaccinated adults do
we also have nearly two years of data to
support these conclusions
we have a case study then
that includes six million kids at least
much more than that i mean those are
confirmed cases
over the course of 22 months
we could say therefore with great
confidence that covet is extremely
unlikely to do significant damage to our
kids
what about the cova vaccine in that case
according to pfizer they've tested it on
2 000 children
we have data from you know 6 million
kids demonstrating their robust natural
immunity versus data from 2 000 children
according to pfizer that says that
allegedly it's safe and effective in the
same age group
we have no data about the long-term
effects of the vaccine in kids well we
can how could we
and by long-term here i mean we don't
have we don't know the effects beyond a
few weeks
in this relatively small sample size for
the vaccine
that's an important point too because
consider this report from reuters
published a couple of days ago
maybe you didn't hear about this there's
a reason if you didn't the headline is
sweden and denmark paused modernicova 19
vaccine for younger age groups and it
says quote sweden and denmark said on
wednesday they're pausing the use of
modernist coven 19 vaccine for younger
age groups after reports of possible
rare cardiovascular side effects the
swedish health agency said it would
pause using the shot for people born in
1991
so that's anyone 30 or younger
as data pointed to an increase of
myocarditis and pericarditis among
youths and young adults that have been
vaccinated those conditions involve an
inflammation of the heart or its lining
the health agency said the connection is
especially clear when it comes to
modernist vaccine spike vacs especially
after the second dose
but they said that the risk is uh is
very small
okay the risk is small they say
we don't know the exact connection if
there is one
this is also moderna not pfizer
but that's all exactly the point right
the unknowns
meanwhile there are certain things we do
know things we know as certainly as we
can know anything when it comes to this
virus
and one of those things is that covet
itself presents only a very small
miniscule
threat to young kids
we know that more firmly than we know
almost anything else about this virus or
the vaccines that are meant to prevent
it
and so i'm resting on that knowledge on
that data on that science when i say as
a parent of four kids all under 12 that
they're not going to be getting the
vaccine it's just it's not happening
period
we know that california has already
preemptively mandated the vaccine for
all kids in school once this rush job is
complete and the drug is approved for
those age groups they've already said
that it's going to be mandated
i expect many other states to follow
suit who knows what will happen on the
federal level but i think we could
probably make a pretty confident guess
and will the mandates for children go
beyond public schools
it seems certain that it will happen
there in public schools and if you don't
want your kid to take this vaccine
then you're going to reach a point here
where you just have to pull them out of
the government school system
those will be your only choices soon
enough
but will our rulers move to preclude our
kids from general participation in
society
as they're trying to do with adults if
they aren't vaccinated
we'll see you soon enough the real
question is whether this
will be our line in the sand our last
line
there should have been many other lines
but those have all been crossed already
will we allow the government now to
force an unnecessary drug
into our kids bodies
or will this be our metaphorical alamo
you know the issue goes beyond science
it's it's true that my personal reasons
for rejecting the vaccine for my kids
are science based
as i've already explained
this is this is a simple matter of
looking at the data
and making a decision based on that as i
have done
as many other parents have done
but if the government tried to force
this substance into my kids bodies
it wouldn't just be scientifically
unnecessary
it would be basically a total revocation
of my rights as a parent and my kids
rights
the government would be forcing a
medical decision on to my kids not even
because my kids need it
okay so this isn't like a case where my
kids my kid needs a blood transfusion or
uh or they're gonna die and the
government comes and says you gotta do
it
if for some reason i wasn't going to
um that's not what this is
this is not forcing it on the kids
because they need it
we could have we could have a separate
debate about those kinds of situations
that's not what this is this is simply
because the government has decided that
it wants my kids to have it
and if it can do that
if i allow it to do that if we allow it
then well game over
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know whenever i see someone with
puffy eyes all i can think about is how
much better they would look if only they
knew about genusl i mean i talked about
i saw someone with puffy eyes the other
day i went up to them and said excuse me
do you realize your eyes are puffy and
disgusting and they they they looked at
me and i and then that's when i had a
chance to tell them about genusel i
don't know if they appreciated it but
you will if you get jen yourself if
you're one of the millions of americans
male or female who deals with bags and
puffiness under the eyes let me tell you
about genusel serum from chamonix
geniuselum uses plant stem cell
technology to promote visibly healthier
skin and the appearance of younger
healthier eyes genusel's state of the
art technology will become your most
powerful weapon against under eye bags
and puffiness customers everywhere have
been raving about this product my
assistant tessa has been using jen
yourself for the last couple of weeks
and she has not had puffy eyes this
entire time which is good because if she
did she would be fired order now and
save big on genusel's risk-free
introductory offer all orders are up to
50 off so go to genusell.com and enter
mat30 for an extra 30 off today that's
genusell.com genusell.com
all right
let's start with this
from the daily wire this is a
an incredible story okay this is from
the daily wire again it says cook county
state's
state's attorney kim fox's office
refused this
in chicago
refused to charge five men arrested in
connection with a gang-related gun fight
that left at least one person dead and
two wounded even though police requested
a number of felony charges for each
individual suspect because the five men
were mutual combatants
the five men were released leaving
chicago officials including mayor lawyer
light lori lightfoot incensed
the chicago sun times reported that the
men
linked to a deadly gang-related shootout
friday in austin were released from
custody after prosecutors declined to
charge each of them with a pair of
felonies including first-degree murder
even though police sought to charge all
five suspects with murder and aggravated
battery
the outlet noted that the brazen
mid-morning gun fight which left one
shooter dead and two suspects would
extend from an internal dispute
between two factions of the four corner
hustler street gang according to an
internal police report and a law
enforcement source with knowledge of
investigation so
uh to review here
this is a gun fight in the middle of the
day
somebody dies
they arrest
the survivors of the gunfight
and then prosecutors say yeah you know
what
all right
we're gonna let this one slide
not even a slap on the wrist here right
not even give them like a ticket for for
being a public nuisance
um all five suspects were released
without charges on sunday because
according to the state's attorney's
office
listen to this here's the reason why
they're not being charged
because according to the state's
attorney's office they were targeting
each other
so no harm no foul i mean somebody died
but no harm no felt
um a spokeswoman first claimed that
prosecutors had determined that the
evidence was insufficient to meet our
burden of proof to approve felony
charges
even though these guys were out in the
open
shooting at each other but there's not
enough evidence that it happened
um but they didn't specify what evidence
might be necessary to bring charges um
that the police department felt were
warranted
uh later they noted that mutual
combatants was mutual combatants was
cited as the reason for the rejection
a designation the sun times noted refers
to a fight or struggle that two parties
willingly engage in
uh the cook county prosecutor released
another individual from custody last
week for the same reason despite
indications that they were engaging in
gang violence
uh
um you know i i keep scrolling down here
to see the the punch line if there's
something else but that's that's it
they're saying
both both sides agreed to engage
in this gun fight and they were only
shooting at each other
and so we're not going to charge them
with a crime
this is
the chicago
attorney's office
basically what they've done here is they
have in one fell swoop they have
decriminalized gang violence as long as
it's between each other
so if you're a member of one gang and
someone's on your corner there selling
drugs you can go up and shoot them
as as long as you keep it
you know within that it's not as long as
you keep it within uh
[Music]
as long as it's inter-gang violence you
don't involve anybody else
this you know it's bad when when even
mayor lori lightfoot who is herself
a deranged leftist far left
radical lunatic
even she is ticked off about this
because she at least has the sense to
see that this
you're ushering in total chaos is what
you're doing here
you are now abandoning our city to chaos
that's what's happening
um
in fact that's what she said she said if
they do not feel like the criminal
justice system is going to hold them
accountable talking about
violent criminals gang members we're
going to see a level of brazenness that
will send this city into chaos
and we cannot let that happen
it's hard to imagine that it could get
more brazen or more chaotic in a place
like chicago
but that's what that's what they're
looking at
this is so so what i guess dueling is is
can can we have duels now is that back
on the table
has chicago just legalized
dueling so if you have a
beef with another guy you can agree to
meet out at high noon out in the street
shoot at each other
of course
mayor lightfoot has no room to complain
this is the inevitable result
of running these cities according to
leftist policies and philosophies
because what really lies at the root of
it whatever excuse they give kim fox
gives for not filing any charges the
real reason she's not filing charges
is because she just fundamentally
doesn't believe
that it's their fault
she thinks that they're all they're all
victims
you know they're victims of um
of systemic racism
you know this is this is not this is not
anything they're doing of their own free
will and volition
so you can't blame them for it they're
all victims
a violent criminal who goes out in
chicago and kills someone else is
himself a victim as well
that's the mentality that laurie
lightfoot
subscribes to
all these democrats running all the
cities
believe that as well
so kim fox is really just taking it to
its logical conclusion
which is to embrace anarchy and chaos
and to basically abolish the law
completely
all right chris hayes ran a segment last
night in response to
josh hawley who was skeptical about this
claim that school board members are the
victims of widespread intimidation and
death threats
so chris hayes spliced together
holly with clips that are meant to prove
that this is a problem
so chris hayes and his team they went
and they found examples you know trying
to prove that no this
the fbi
and the buy administration going after
parents at school board meetings
this isn't as i have claimed as josh
hawley has claimed it's this is not
about intimidating parents or trying to
silence them
there is in fact a big problem it's not
it's not just that parents are
criticizing school board members or
raising their voices and yelling um they
are there there's death threats there's
violence it's an epidemic and that's why
the doj needs to be involved
chris hayes wants to prove that
so hi so he and his team got together
and they got all the clips they could
find
to try to make that point to try to
prove it
and here's the best they could do let's
watch this
he thinks innocent parents are being
silenced by the
doj for politely disagreeing with their
local government he was indignant as he
asked the deputy attorney general about
the existence of school board threats
and intimidation which is frankly kind
of astounding when the reality of what's
happening on the ground is undeniable
[Music]
is waiting to express one's view at a
school board meeting harassment and
intimidation we know we know who you are
harassment and intimidation what did
those terms mean in the context of a
local school board meeting the death
threat was you're going to get knifed
going to get a
you're dead tell me where the line is
with parents expressing their concerns
waiting for hours in the school board
meetings we've all seen the videos this
happened in my state people were
actually throwing fists and hitting each
other outside the auditorium this
evening after the board unanimously
voted to approve requiring mass if this
isn't a deliberate attempt to chill
parents
from showing up at school board meetings
for their elected school board i don't
know what is one of the board members
they called for her and her children to
choke and die another one said that the
board member was about to get ruined
another one suggested another board
member die by suicide calling also for
harassment and bullying of board members
you are attempting to intimidate them
you are attempting to silence them it
has an effect on you that you can't
really put into words
when someone describes
the way they want to
come into your home
and end your life i cannot believe that
an attorney general of the united states
is engaging in this kind of conduct and
frankly i can't believe that you are
sitting here today
defending it
josh hawley's very upset we're going to
send him that montage just to read him
into a little bit of what's been going
on at the local level but i suspect he
knows
okay so there you go i want you to see
all that because that's that's the worst
of the worst i can assume that chris
hayes
uh msnbc if there were
more compelling examples of uh of
parents engaging in actual violence
intimidation death threats
that they would have let left those on
the cutting room floors that's the best
they could do
and what do we see there
we saw exactly one clip of an actual
parent
engaging in what you could arguably call
intimidation saying saying we know who
you are
of course
that that kind of language you you hear
from antifa blm i mean this is
you have to really stretch to see that
as a threat
um
it could just as easily be a threat to
we're going to vote you off the school
board
but even if you hang even if you give
them that
that's the one clip they they were able
to show
verified confirmed of an actual parent
saying something that that you could
interpret as a threat if you wanted to
and then what else did we have we had a
news report of parents throwing fists
okay well there have been a handful of
cases of that
where parents on both sides get into
heated scuffles
and no one is seriously injured
but that's on both sides
and then you had a couple of school
board members
alleging claiming that they had received
death threats
we don't actually see those they just
tell us that they've gotten them
maybe they have maybe they haven't
i'm sorry but i'm not gonna i don't
believe it on face value i just don't
especially when you have so much when
there's so much to be gained
by claiming that you're getting the
death threats
maybe you are
but i would need to see them
because i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna take your word for it
especially when this is the this is the
kind of reflexive move of everybody
these days uh especially public
officials
when they're getting criticism and
they're facing backlash
every time we are i'm getting death
threats now maybe you are if you are
that's very bad
but also maybe you're not
all even if you it let's just pretend
that all of that is is those are all
valid examples of
you know
intimidation threats if we believe all
of that we just saw
i mean considering how many school board
school boards there are across the
country
how many meetings and protests there
have been
does that just really that
you think that justifies the department
of justice getting involved you think
that
is a reason for the fbi
to get involved
that's the best you could do
because i can tell you something right
now if someone wanted to make a montage
of the things that are done and said at
blm rallies
and by antifa
you know they're not going to have to
grasp at straws nearly as much
and we know fbi doj never involved there
so this only all you have to do is look
listen to the other side as they're
trying to justify this
that's all the evidence that you need
that it is not justifiable
that this is indeed about
intimidating
and shutting down silencing parents
this is a warning
you know it's it's better to stay home
it's better not to come to the meetings
because if you do
then you're going to end up on the fbi's
radar we're watching you okay that's
that's what the fbi is saying
all right there was a
another school shooting yesterday this
one was the circumstances of this one a
little bit different
from what we normally think of when we
when we hear about school shootings
this is from the local nbc affiliate
it says four people were hurt wednesday
morning during a shooting at timber view
high school in arlington according to
police arlington police said that there
was a fight between students on the
second floor of the school when one of
the students pulled out a gun
and
that student is 18 years old and we
still don't know a lot of the details
here but he fired the gun and he and
four people got hit
we we still don't know if he
was firing at the person that he was
having a fight with and then
accidentally hit the other people or if
he just started spraying bull i i don't
think we know that yet
um
and also we hear that it's a fight
there's a there's a
video going around claiming that it's a
footage of this fight
that led to the shooting and it's not
really a fight so much as one kid is
just getting absolutely pummeled
and uh and assaulted by another
and in that case we don't know which kid
is which so there's a lot of unknown
but for the left in the media they
they know as much as they need to know
there's a shooting it's at a school and
so that means um let's start shilling
for gun control and so we've seen that
of course on social media right away
this connection with uh with gun control
here's just one example chris murphy
senator chris murphy in connecticut uh
he posted what he what he says what he
claims is a screenshot of a text message
conversation between a kid at this
school and um
and his and his mother
um saying there's a school shooting and
he says read this it's from today in
texas each day you choose to be too busy
to join the anti-gun violence movement
you endorse this as the new normal for
our kids for your kids
and of course
with
the people promoting gun control as is
always the case in the aftermath of
incidents like this
what they failed to mention
is that there were already a whole a
number of of laws in place
that
had already made this very illegal
so if laws in and of themselves were
able to prevent this then it should not
have happened in the first place
so this guy
not a kid he's a he's a a grown man 18
years old
um he brought a gun to school
that's definitely against the law
despite what caricature you the left may
have in their head of texas
it's not legal for students to bring
guns to school in texas i got news for
you
um
so that's against all he broke that law
uh also he's 18 years old
and you can't carry a handgun at 18
in texas you got to be 21.
um so that's also against the law
and he's um and he shot four people
which is also against the law
so a whole number of laws that he broke
and is going to rightly pay the price
for
the question that we that we have to ask
chris murphy and that chris murphy and
people like him will never answer
clearly is
what other laws if those laws didn't
stop this
then what law would have
what additional law
if somebody is breaking is is committing
an act
in which they they break 20 laws
do you think adding another so that they
break 21 instead of just 20 is that what
difference is that going to make
as far as being in the the anti-gun
violence movement i don't even know what
that means the anti
sure yeah we're all against gun violence
um
i i'm against people falling victim to
any form of violence with any with any
kind of weapon
so i'll one-up you chris uh chris murphy
i'm
anti-web violence of all kinds
if someone is falling victim unless it's
self-defense i'm i am against uh
violence committed by any kind of weapon
at all
i am anti-uh i'm anti-violence
if it's unjustified violence
so you you've you're focusing only on
guns i'll go
i'll go
further than that
the question is what additional laws can
actually prevent this
because those forms of violence are
already illegal in about 10 different
ways at least
unless you live in chicago where
apparently actually now it's legal
but you've got to take that up with the
democrats that are running those cities
so that's not an issue here
although
i do see
another point that can be made
when you hear about yet another shooting
out of school even if the circumstances
here are a little bit different from
again what you normally think of when we
think about mass shootings at schools
but still it's more violence in the
school system
and i agree that violence in the school
system is a problem
all kinds of violence
you know there are many schools
especially in the city where
uh maybe kids are getting shot every day
thank god but there is violence every
day
they might be using their fists and
throwing chairs at each other but
there's violence every single day
in many of these schools it is it's
chaos
i agree that that's a perhaps a big
problem
when are we going to look at the system
itself i mean the school system itself
maybe there's a problem with the school
system itself
maybe this is just another reason to
actually homeschool your kids
it could be an argument for that
in fact it boggles my mind
that we hear that you know there's a
violence epidemic in the schools there's
a bullying epidemic in the schools
the parents and the family members of
the shooter in this case have come out
and said that he was bullied and that's
where he was responding to that you know
he'd been bullied for years and years
pretty common excuse you hear in these
kinds of cases i don't know if it's true
or not
but there's bullying there's violence
and yet the same people who tell us that
about the school system
they also tell us
that well you got to send your kid to
public school in order for them to be
properly socialized
you got to send them into this
environment where bullying and violence
is out of control and an epidemic
according to them
but you have to send your kids into that
so they can be properly socialized
you wouldn't want to keep them home with
you
then they're going to be weird then
they're going to be socially awkward
as opposed to the public school system
where you got kids shooting each other
getting into fights every day
a bullying epidemic again according to
to you
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
yet another reason to keep your kids
home and homeschool them all right let's
uh here's something from justin trudeau
that i i have to just read because i i'm
i am sincerely confused by it justin
trudeau trudeau tweeted this out
yesterday he said
people across the country are lighting
candles to honor indigenous women girls
and
two s l g b t q q i a plus people who
are missing or have been murdered
we must continue to work together raise
awareness and advocate to end this
ongoing national tragedy hashtag sisters
in spirit
i'm honestly curious did his cat walk
across the keyboard
did he have some kind of mini
seizure or spasms in the middle of
typing 2sl
lgbtqia plus
what even is that i actually
i was looking that up out of curiosity
because i i i is that is that is that
what the acronym is now 2sl and
apparently that means
okay 2sl gbt qqia plus
that is two spear okay two spirit
lesbian gay bisexual trans queer
questioning intersex and asexual plus
and then everybody else we're lumping in
there
so now we're taking two spirits
we're not even we're not only including
two spirit but they're getting um
they're getting first place now they're
getting pride of place right at the very
beginning two-spirit
that's very good
for the
12 or 13 people in the world who
identify as two-spirit whatever the hell
that's supposed to mean
it's good that we put them right there
at the front of the acronym
thanks for that justin trudeau
next we got billy eilish she was
performing at a concert in texas and
decided to speak out against the texas
abortion law and uh hey i mean maybe she
makes uh a compelling case you know
billy eilish
she's an eloquent and intelligent person
so let's let's just hear what she has to
say about the texas abortion law she may
surprise us
hey
[Applause]
i am so
sick and tired
of old men
men in general
sorry
but old ones especially
shut the [ __ ] up about our bodies
oh my god
shut up like
and i have to be honest with you
that
when they made to the law
i almost didn't want to do this show all
right so [ __ ] shut up billy
because i wanted her
so i i i wanted to give her a chance
maybe she had something interesting and
intelligent to say but
apparently not
all she wants to say is that we uh that
we men
you know we should
shut up about about her body and about
women's no one's talking about your body
billy eilish no one cares
no one is talking about that
who who in the pro-life movement is
talking about women's bodies
who who where is this happening
who are you referring to
all we are doing all we ever talk about
when it comes to this issue
our focus as pro-lifers is on the child
that's our point
that's what we're trying to defend
is the body and the dignity and the
moral worth of that child
all we ever hear from the other side
stop talking about our bodies
our bodies
you stopped talking about them
we don't care that's not what we're
talking about
you know when you have one side of the
debate that feels the need to const all
they ever do is lie
they will simply never engage honestly
on this issue they they won't do it they
never have
never
when you've got one side of the debate
that always
lies about what the other side is
actually saying
well that should that should tell you
who's on who's on the right and wrong
side of this thing all right next from
the daily wire it says the u.s space
agency uh
nasa plans to conduct a mission next
month to deflect a pair of asteroids far
out in deep space to keep them from
threatening earth
dub the dart mission or the double
asteroid redirection test
the national aeronautics and space
agency will spend we'll send a
spacecraft to a pair of asteroids
on november 24th a bit of spacex falcon
9 rocket
um and if all goes according to plan
it will smash into one of the two
asteroids known as diddy moon
at roughly
13 500 miles per hour nearly a full year
later
uh diddy moon is more than
500 feet wide and uh diddy moon sounds
like a i don't know a teletubbie or
something more than 500 feet wide and
orbits a much larger space rock known as
didimus which is five times as big
and so that's the plan anyway
there are these two
two big asteroids that potentially could
threaten to cause devastating uh damage
to earth and who knows maybe wipe out
all life on earth i'm not sure
and so they're sending
these these rockets out to deflect them
before that happens
and my first question to that is why
this was our way out
are you gonna ruin that for us nasa
but then i am giving a little bit of
hope given that this is the the us
government after all
and so it seems there's there's a you
know pretty good chance it seems like
that um they could go and accidentally
deflect this thing into earth so it
seems a pretty good chance that this
thing was never going to threaten earth
at all
and they've hatched this plan and
they're going to say they're going to
deflect it right into us now both
asteroids are going to hit us at the
same time
which you'd have to admit would be
pretty hilarious
if that were to happen the means
before we all perish in a ball of fire
the means would just be tremendous well
with cryptocurrency rapidly increasing
in popularity now is a great time to
tell you about alto crypto ira
uh with ulta crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes you get into investing in
crypto um you need to do it in a tax
advantage retirement account altos
crypto ira is the easy way to get crypto
into an ira you could trade all you want
without the tax headache
you can create an account in just a few
minutes it's very easy to do uh you can
invest with as little as ten dollars so
you don't need a lot of money to get
started you don't need a lot of time to
get started and one of the best things
there's no setup charges at all secure
trading 24 7 through alto's integration
with coinbase 80 plus coins are
available including bitcoin ethereum and
many others there's multiple ways to
fund your your account uh you can make a
cash contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira or roll over an old 401k
it's all very easy to do and now is the
time to do it open an alto crypto ira
account with as little as 10 just go to
altoira dot com slash matt that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash go to alto
ira.com matt
all right let's get now to reading the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
uh let's see mfn says matt's dog
situation is worth its own episodes
so my dog has already replaced me in my
family and now you want the dog to
replace me on the show as well you want
this
my whole home life is now about this
damn dog and now you want the show to be
about the dog too
is that what you want me i'll just bring
the dog in here have him sit here for an
hour in front of the camera
don't answer that because a lot of you
probably would prefer that and i don't
want to hear it
uh tai says matt i wanted to know if
you've struggled giving up nfl football
in the wake of their support for blm in
addition to virtue signaling on the
field with phrases such as end racism
the league has apparently given millions
to blm i know for me personally the nfl
is hard to give up
but i have contemplated it
uh
yes they answer your question is i i
have found it i have found it difficult
um
i have many ways of rationalizing it
i've given up most professional sports i
i used to be an nba fan up until
recently
but with this most recent round of blm
virtue signaling
um when it was
virtue signaling on steroids starting
about a year two years ago
um
uh you know i couldn't do any more so i
do it anymore so i can't watch the mba i
don't watch it anymore i gave that up
uh the nfl i do try to rationalize it in
that number one it's not nearly as bad
as somebody as especially the nba
um
there are plenty of nfl players
yeah one thing i like about nfl players
for one thing one thing i've always
liked about the nfl about football in
general is that it seems to attract a
lot of um
people of faith religious people
you hear nfl players after games and
people make fun of them for this but
you know talking about they had a big
game they scored touchdowns and you
always hear nfl players even the big
stars say i give glory to god for that
and you hear even christians mocking
that as if it's silly
i think it's fantastic i mean we should
give glory to god in all things and
every time i hear an nfl player say
something like that i think it's great
yeah you have a big game
give glory to god
and i i think that stuff really makes a
difference
it seems small but to have
athletes who are glorifying god even in
small ways
it makes a difference in the culture
so
you know i balance that and but it is it
is rationalization i suppose i i admit
that
i just enjoy watching football and i
enjoy watching it with my family and
there's part of me that i that i feel
you know i don't want to let the left
take this away from me it's something
that that my family enjoys
is it a rationalization again i i admit
that it is
uh ted kaczynski
apparently a fan of the show says when
grown ass adults refer to a grown-ass
man as daddy who is not their real
father
what's your point ted
i didn't hear you in the 90s making this
criticism of puff daddy fans so
i think some hypocrisy on your part
um misinformation says tell the school
board people that activists harassing
them at their house etc is just part of
the process
that is part of the process and you know
apparently even following them into a
bathroom and filming them according to
joe biden part of the process
um
and uh
mo words says to the pa legislator guy
there are plenty of laws that are not in
men's favor look at family law and court
rulings men have to fight for equal
custody pay alimony and uh and child
support well right i mean when it comes
to the law
there's no question that
the sexes are unequal
and are treated unequally before the law
but that women are the beneficiaries in
that case
now some people are more equal than
others and when it comes to law women
are the more equal in the more equal
category
women have because of their sex they
have legal rights
that men don't have
and let's just we could start and end
with the fact
that um women are judge jury and
executioner over their own kids
and so if a man and woman conceive a
child
for the first nine months of that
child's existence
the woman has absolute authority
to kill that child if she wants even if
the man protests
and there are many cases like that
which are unspeakably horrific and
tragic i hear from men like this
now of course there are plenty of cases
on the other side where you have scumbag
cowardly men pressuring and trying to
force black male women into getting
abortions that that obviously happens
um
jeffrey tubin over at uh over at cnn is
an example of that kind of guy
a lot of cases on the reverse where
you've got men pleading with their you
know girlfriends
less often wives
not to abort the children
and they do it anyway
and that's a case of uh and this is the
way the law is set up total helplessness
on the part of men
so you give some other good examples but
i think that right there shows the way
the law really works this coming tuesday
october 12th we're making backstage
extra exciting instead of the usual
daily wire studio we'll be live
streaming our conversation on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville doing what we do best which
is making sense this will be an event
and a live stream unlike any other we've
done before and we're thrilled to be
able to share it with all of you plus
we'll be making some extremely exciting
announcements which you will not want to
miss uh so be sure to tune in join
myself ben shapiro candace owens jeremy
bourne michael knowles andrew clavin and
our live audience for a backstage like
never before tuesday's live stream will
begin at 8 30 pm eastern 7 30 p.m
central so head to dailywire.com or
dailywireyoutube to catch the show when
it airs and also as the legacy media
continues to spin the news our newest
podcast morning wire continues to top
the apple and spotify charts and we're
continuing our commitment to bringing
you the news without any hidden agenda
it's the only daily podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we're
working over time to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe now and start listening
to morning wire on applespotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we
returned to the murky swamps of tiktok
ready to cancel everything in our path
and right away a good candidate presents
itself here's a feminist woman named
christy who looks exactly like every
other feminist woman named christy that
you've ever you've ever met if you've
had the misfortune of meeting more than
one just as a quick introduction to
christy
uh this is not the video we're going to
focus on today but i just want to play
one of her most recent contributions
here she is on the issue of race listen
in honor of this
white people stitch this how many white
people i make it my personal business
to have complex conversations about race
with any and all white people that i
encounter
complex conversations about race with
all white people that you encounter how
does that work are you stopping people
on the street excuse me sir i'd like to
have a complex conversation about race
with you maybe you go door-to-door like
a jehovah's witness except significantly
more annoying
i shudder at the thought of being stuck
next to her on an airplane for three
hours just one more reason to choose a
seat in the exit row i guess
uh
the exit would be for her not for me in
that case anyway that gives you an idea
of where she's uh where she's coming
from now let's get to the main event
i'm here to double down on the video
that made me go viral
most men
are rapists
and by that i mean most cis
heteronormative men there's a reason we
say we live in a rape culture most rapes
go unreported some even unknown and the
way rape is portrayed and glamorized in
movies and media misrepresents what most
rape actually looks like
let's just look at the updated
definition of rape so that everybody's
clear penetration no matter how slight
of the vagina or anus or any other body
part or object or oral penetration by a
sex organ of another person without the
consent of the victim are you buying
somebody drinks with the goal of getting
them drunk enough so that they can't
consent
rapist
coercing somebody into sex rapist
guilting or manipulating someone into
having sex with you
rapist
dating coaches and pickup artists have
normalized this kind of behavior and if
you engage in any of those things you'll
be known as a rapist
is your just the tip joke funny now
always with the hair they all have the
same hair do they go to like the hair
salon and say uh yeah i'm a shrill
feminist just so go ahead and do do what
you do
now you notice how she lets gay men off
the hook at the start because apparently
male on male rape doesn't exist this
will come as welcome news to everybody
who's going to prison
from there she uh gives us a definition
of rape that few could argue with rape
is having sex with someone performing
any kind of sexual act with them
without their consent yeah that's
obviously what the term means but then
she performs the trick that has become
so common in our culture a trick that
has led to lots of confusion and to
very many ruined lives
by manipulating the word consent you'll
notice that she doesn't pull out the old
webster's to tell us what the word
consent means she does that with rape
but not consent because if she had we'd
see that consent means agreement to do
something
that's it if you agree to do it you
consent it
if you were forced to do it you didn't
consent so it's that simple
she provides the example of a man it's
always a man as if women don't do this
a man getting a woman drunk in order to
have sex with her now if someone is
trying to intoxicate another person
with the explicit goal of taking
advantage of them and the other person
has no sober intention of engaging in
any kind of sexual activity
then yes that could be a form of
removing consent
but the problem is that in most cases
where alcohol is involved especially
somewhere like a college campus you have
two people in a sexually charged
environment both getting drunk
and then both having sex while drunk
who's the rapist there both of them are
they raping each other
well the school rape tribunals always
put the blame on men in fact i'm not
aware of a single case where a woman has
been charged or even accused of rape
after a mutual drunk sex
the onus always falls on men
from there she makes rape into an even
more obscure concept by claiming that
men again always men because women never
do this
men who guilt manipulate or coerce women
into sex are rapists now
it's possible to imagine forms of
coerced sex that would count as rape if
you tell a woman to have sex with you or
you'll kill her that's coercion and it's
obviously rape
but she says that that most
most straight men are rapists which
means she's talking about far less dire
and more generalized versions of
manipulation
essentially what feminists mean when
they say this is that trying to convince
a woman to have sex
using any form of persuasion at all
is rape
which is another way of saying that a
man who tries to initiate sex
even with his own wife potentially is a
rapist
you would have to mean that if you're
trying to support the claim that most
men are rapists
which is obviously ludicrous
and worse than ludicrous as this
mentality has again ruined the lives of
many men by providing women with the
framework
to accuse their consensual sexual
partners of rape after the fact
the word consent
means what it means in reality if you
agree to do it
if you're not
forced but you agreed
then you've consented
even if you did it but you didn't want
to
even if you did it and you felt bad
about it later
even if you did it but only because you
thought it was the only way to secure
promotion at work in all of those cases
in any case like them
you have agreed you have participated of
your own free will and volition you were
not raped
but even if you weren't raped
does that mean that you weren't used
is it possible for someone to be
sexually used and yet not raped yes in
fact it's possible and it happens all
the time and it's bad but it's not rape
at the end of the video she says via
text on the screen there that feeling
entitled to someone's body for sexual
pleasure is a rapist mentality
now it isn't necessarily
but it is a perverse and degraded
mentality
it's also the mentality that many people
in our culture men and women share
the moment that we ripped the sexual act
out of the loving and committed confines
of marriage we turned it into a purely
selfish act performed by individuals for
their own gratification
everyone involved in hookup culture is
using someone's body for sexual pleasure
everyone who looks at porn is doing
that um
most of the people men and women on
dating apps are pursuing exactly that
are they all rapists no i mean some of
them are by by statistics would seem to
indicate but but most of them aren't the
problem as i've described in the past is
that in our culture today
we have no moral language to govern sex
except consent that's the only moral
guide that we have left because we've
thrown everything else out
the idea that sex used to be loving used
to be
sex is supposed to be loving is supposed
to be committed
all of that we've thrown out
and we've left only consent
as the one single moral rule left to
govern the sexual act
and a lot of people like the person in
the video there
have without realizing it notice the
problem
they may live they've looked around and
they've seen that wow i mean gee
so often
sex in our culture today is it's
degraded
it seems immoral amoral
people are just using each other as
objects
i mean to to use someone else simply as
basically a glorified masturbatory aid
as just this tool for you to
get your thrills that's a terrible thing
it's dehumanizing
and and it is
but because they're committed to this
idea
that we all need to be libertines
that we can't you know that the the the
concept that sex is supposed to be
loving and committed that's patriarchal
that's religious we if they're committed
to that
so they've thrown that out
all they have left is consent
and so they decide that okay well all
these cases here these are all
violations of consent
and that's how i'm going to be able to
condemn them
they're not
but in many cases they're still immoral
and that's why today
even though even though she she like so
many feminists on this issue
there may be there may be closer to the
to the point they're closer to the truth
than they realize
still i have to say that today she is
canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike cormina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell agrees
to a temporary debt ceiling increase
president biden's approval rating
craters and espn suspends at sage steel
for saying in the unseeable that's today
on the benchmark show give it a listen